die vereinten nationen ersucht in
österreich im juli 2011 die
transporteinheit im rahmen von united
nations interim force in lebanon kurz
uni viel bei zu stellen
insgesamt stellen 35 staaten rund 12.000
soldatinnen und soldaten für diese un
mission ab diese führen patrouillen im
einsatzraum durch betreiben checkpoints
und unterstützen die libanesischen
sicherheitskräfte am 6 september hat der
ministerrat die entsendung von etwa 160
soldatinnen und soldaten beschlossen
ende november wurde das haupt kontinent
nach entsprechender ausbildung in den
libanon verlegt die neue heimat der
österreichischen friedenssoldaten ist
das hauptquartier der un mission
es befindet sich in natura im südwesten
des libanon 110 kilometer von bayern
entfernt
das camp ist rund 23 kilometer lang 400
bis 500 meter breit und liegt direkt am
mittelmeer
kommandant des österreichischen
kontingents ist der burgenländer
oberstleutnant thomas erkinger dem
auslands erfahrenen offizier und besteht
in österreich als bataillonskommandant
das jägerbataillon 19
wir stellen wir meinen kontingents
commander neben einem nationalen element
das für die versorgung zuständig ist
eine logistik komponieren eine
versorgungskompanie im rahmen dieser
kompanie haben wir die aufgaben
transporte durchzuführen für personal
und material im gesamten einsatzraum und
speziell auch bis in den raum bei dort
wo also der flughafen untersee haben
sich befinden
darüber hinaus betreiben wir
verschiedenste versorgungseinrichtungen
innerhalb des camps wie die tankstelle
wie im bereich der flicks des umschlages
im bereich der küche aber auch
verschiedene warenlager wo wir so für
die für die lagerung und für die ausgabe
verantwortlich sind für diese aufgaben
wurden vom dänischen kontingent rund 100
fahrzeuge vom geländewagen über
tankfahrzeuge bis zum sattelschlepper
als kommandant der transport company
führt mallorquinische jene soldaten die
im libanon die kernaufgabe des
bundeswehrkontingents übernehmen
unsere aufgabe besteht primär darin
personen und güter im einsatzraum zu
verbringen und umzuschlagen
die versorgung der eigenen truppe
sicherzustellen zu berge und
instandsetzungsmaßnahmen umzusetzen
dabei obliegt ihm und seinem team unter
anderem die richtige zusammenstellung
von konvois am 28 november 2011 wurde
das dänische kontinent feierlich
verabschiedet
zum festakt kamen neben dem force
commander generalmajor alberto attacke
was aus spanien
auch hochrangige vertreter der einzelnen
uni viel nationen als vertreter des
bundesheeres war der stellvertretende
streitkräfte kommandant generalmajor
dieter heidecke zu diesem festakt
angereist
nach dem gemeinsamen abschreiten der
front wurde die dänische fahne eingeholt
und die österreichische fahne gehisst
anschließend übernahm oberstleutnant
erkinger von force commander die un
fahne
dr ernst benischke ist der arzt
inkontinenz er kümmert sich um die
gesundheit der österreichischen soldaten
im einsatz frauen dagegen satz ist so
etwas wie der hausarzt für die soldaten
und dazu mit die aufgaben sämtliche
erkrankungen auftreten zu behandeln und
zu schauen dass das kontigent so weit
wie möglich gesund bleibt unterstützt
wird er unter anderem durch
kooperationen strobl
ich bin hier tätig als rettungssanitäter
meine aufgabe liegt darin den arzt zu
unterstützen und den transport von
personen um den direkten kontakt zur
libanesischen bevölkerung weiter
auszubauen trifft oberst leitung per
finger in regelmäßigen abständen den
bürgermeister von acura muss daher
gemeinsam besuchten sie ende november
eine schule die österreicher wurden
dabei vom direktor den lehrern sowie den
schülerinnen und schülern sehr herzlich
aufgenommen
das österreichische bundesheer ist seit
1967 im nahen osten an un
friedensmission beteiligt und genießt
aufgrund der langjährigen erfahrung und
kompetenz in dieser region eine hohe
reputation
seit 1960 haben mehr als 90.000
österreichische soldaten und zivile
helfer an über 50 internationalen
friedens unterstützenden und humanitären
missionen teilgenommen